well we're back at it again reject
nation it's Greg Alba here and I'm John
Humphrey today is December 11th the time
we're filming this review thank you to
Disney for letting us attend one of your
screenings of Star Wars the last Jedi
people still don't have access to the
channel so not sure when this video is
actually going up from the past hello
and just see if you guys a heads up this
is gonna be a non-spoiler review and I
feel like it's gonna be really
challenging to talk about this movie
that's spoiling something but don't
worry we edit so we'll make sure we
don't spoil anything for you guys but we
will be doing a spoiler review a little
bit later on in the week so keep your
eye out for that now before we hop into
this review I wanted to give a shout out
to the real rejects video sponsor and
that is the app called Stardust Stardust
is this awesome app that allows you to
do 30-second reactions for any film TV
show or trailer John and I have been
using it a lot and one of the main
reasons we use it especially for movies
that we just watched is it gives you an
overall consensus of what we thought in
30 seconds and plus it's just fun to do
30 second movie reviews I used to love
that idea of doing that on YouTube
challenge it's a good challenge
especially or something like Star Wars
so if you don't want to watch our full
movie review or you want to get our
quick highlights of what we think before
review is out or you want to know what
we think of stuff that we wouldn't
necessarily review on the channel yeah
make sure to download the star dust app
and follow us at the real rejects first
people a lot of your favorite youtubers
are using it including us come on out
all right here we go Star Wars the last
Jedi
what can I really tell you guys it sucks
it's one of the work can I just get this
mic here for one second I think it's my
favorite Star Wars movie of all time
yeah that's high praise yeah I really do
think that would you think John I
hesitate to get that that big out the
gate cuz it's only been a few hours I
definitely think this might be the one I
appreciate the most I mean it's
unfolding in my head over the end and I
really liked some of the stuff they did
here and it really compelled me I really
do love it I think this film is an epic
masterpiece in so many ways one of my
comments when we left the movie was and
you can't really say anything when
you're on the Disney Lots when we got
the car what I said was you know the
force awakens was a big
film but I wouldn't call it like an epic
film this one to me feels like an epic
it feels like the war in Star Wars yeah
you know those kind of Lord of the Rings
yeah I really don't want to spoil
anything so whatever I say I'll try to
link it to knowing that the trailers
already hinted at that or it gave it
away and this film you have essentially
like three different stories going on in
this movie that are all intertwining
it's a super crazy adventure because it
starts off big as it goes you realize
even though the movie started off big
it's really a build up film yeah because
there's so much story they're
encapsulating and what's crazy about
this movies you got three different main
stories by the time it all comes to the
end you're like wow that was smoothly
told you know yeah it never felt like
over convoluted you never got a sense
that they didn't care about any of the
characters in fact I felt like they made
a lot of characters even better this
time around
yeah yeah yeah when there's a big sense
of tension I got out of it because
there's so many moving parts that are
all kind of heading in the same
direction there are no like subplots
that aren't related to the main conflict
at hand yeah so it does make it feel
like the tension of a battle you know
like I'm a war my favorite parts of this
movie have to be with Luke and Rey Luke
and Rey and kylo Ren actually which is
weird because I wasn't the biggest I
love a fan I really wasn't but they
don't I walk out of this and I'm like
dude he is one of the strongest they
have Adam driver kills it in this role
and I felt like what they gave him to do
here excellent you know you watch the
trailers and you're like they gave a lot
away then you watch the movie like they
didn't have anything like that because
there's it's it's a dense movie and I
was not expecting that
yeah and it's averted my expectations a
lot of the time in kylo is exemplary of
that you know he compelled me a lot and
he's got a surprisingly nuanced sort of
story yeah you know and I loved where
that I really felt like we got to
understand kylo at a much deeper level
other than Darth Vader to point out yeah
yeah yeah I mean he's grown up some from
like the kind of Punk sort of wasn't the
first one you know he only smashes one
you know yeah lady panel in this movie
and what's fascinating about it is when
he first takes off the masculine force
awakens a lot of people laugh
have you seen your like this guy seems
like a whiny nude when he as the force
awakens progresses and in this movie he
doesn't really have the mask for a good
chunk of his scenes and he's so much
better like I buy him like I believe
this kylo guy I wasn't expecting to walk
away from this film raving about kylo
Ren but damn is he kill it Rey man what
they do with hurt and Luke Luke is
excellent yes he is excellent and the
scenes he has with Daisy Ridley are so
damn good I can see how it's reminiscent
of Empire Strikes Back because you get a
lot of focus on what it means to be a
Jedi and who you are as a Jedi and then
you know Luke and Rey semi reminiscent
of something like Yoda and Luke and
Empire Strikes Back and then you only
different dynamic Oh totally what one of
the other you know really strong parts
of the movie yes sort of watching that
play out from another angle and that's
yeah that's what it starts feeling like
it's own thing and it doesn't have that
force awakens new hope syndrome I really
feel like Rian Johnson understood the
depth of what it means to be a Jedi and
it was really cool to get back to that
in this specific film yeah the Jedi
religion yeah yeah religious scene the
training sequences and seen their
interact I want to give anything away
it's like everything you see in the
trailer it's all there in the movie
things you wanted from the trailer it's
all there but there's so much more and a
lot of surprises that keep coming at you
and Poe you know Oscar Isaac I kept
thinking about how in the first movie
everyone was like man Oscar Isaacs
really underused in this movie yeah and
then here he is used to great effect
from the very beginning of this movie
you're like oh yeah yeah totally and I
really liked what they do with his arc
as well like again I'm not gonna give
the major themes away but he's again
used in a way that sort of subverts your
expectations while also giving you the
type of character you want yes that's
across the board for this movement he's
yeah he's awesome what I've been saying
for the longest time about force awakens
was I always felt that I was saying this
before even that trailers to last Jedi
came out was that the force awakens was
intentionally doing familiar set up so
they could come at us with surprises in
the sequels
I had a strong feeling that this was all
part of their master plan like yeah
let's introduce a force awakens have a
couple of new things in there but give a
sense of familiarity with a new hope and
then we'll really start twisting the
tables around and turning everything
upside down in the sequels and that's
exactly what they've done here and you
see that just alone with the characters
and it's film introduces a new character
played by Kelly Marie Tran who you might
have seen on college humor she's this
Asian woman who is deeper in the trailer
I want to tell you guys and she's really
one of the highlights of this movie and
her involvement in the storyline makes
another beloved character so much more
interesting absolutely and you also see
emperor's snow and the trailers you get
some pretty damn good scenes with Snoke
in this movie yeah dude award that man
award this man this is mocap doesn't
make it any less cuz he's everything Jax
does for mocap is exactly what he would
do without mocap it's got a camera
pointed at your face to me make sure it
gets all your yes motion to me mocap is
just another form of makeup like when
you see Gary Oldman in the darkest hour
it's like you're not good while he's
under all that makeup that's why he
kills it as Snoke in this movie it's
it's cool because force awakens sets him
up you really get a much better idea of
who Snoke is in this movie any circus
kills it man he is he's intimidating
he's creepy you really believe the
Menace and the power of this guy and
another character that I was surprised
by that I like I even enjoyed watching
him more it was Dhamma Gleason general
Hux yeah well the thing is this movie
funnier
yeah to me a surprising element of humor
through again sort of subverting my
expectations in different moments
because yeah through a few characters
but especially general Hux there isn't
like an underlying humor in his semi
[ __ ] miss I mean they don't do a Marvel
thing where it's like this film is
jam-packed with humor yeah yeah they're
not like a bumbling [ __ ] but there is
you know there are some very intentional
humorous moments and it comes from read
yeah from the character and from his
status yeah like that and you don't seem
in the trailer you know he's in the
movie he's credited on IMDB Benicio del
Toro is his character name DJ
won't give anything away about the guy
but then you see how fits into this
the world pretty well Donavan like oh
yeah he's in guardians oh yes very
different very different characters and
Benicio gets I can't give it away but
it's like the cool Benicio that I grew
up watching yeah hearken back to that
time where you're like oh I guess they
just kind of let him do whatever yeah
yeah they let him experiment with the
role it was a nice like eccentric
performance you know to help add flavor
Carrie Fisher Carrie Fisher what was
cool about Carrie Fisher of how Rian
Johnson specifically wrote for her
whenever you get into a moment where
you're like honestly like even it's it's
one spoiler it says you know it pays
homage in the credit in memory of Carrie
Fisher Myers is a shock but I found very
interesting about how they approach Leia
in this film Rian Johnson wrote Laird
more attuned to how Carrie Fisher
actually behaves and talked yeah which
was refreshing to see Princess Leia in a
trilogy of original trilogy is very
specific and her personality here they
let go well how would layer grow average
how would her personality change let's
make it more along the lines of Carrie
Fisher so Carrie Fisher got to be more
like herself but it totally fits cuz
she's our Princess Leia and I love the
usage of her in this movie perfectly
used and Suzanne Carrie Fisher trying to
be young Princess Leia this is a
grown-up princess later much more mature
Princess Leia Organa yeah you know and
and she's a leader and I like that her
storyline had a lot to do with themes of
leadership that's integral to a movie
like this you know to discuss not only
why we fight but how yeah and and you
know in which with what nuances and
which yes things in mind want to mention
Laura Dern is in this anything about her
so I don't want to give anything away
good heretic laura dern in this movie it
was another nice surprise I really felt
like no character was wasted whatsoever
if he ever felt that way about any Star
Wars movie I really don't feel that way
in this movie every time a character
shows up even at first when you're like
oh I feel like they don't really know
doing this character or what's the point
of having this actor in this role yeah
eventually just be patient with the film
you can see Rian Johnson was like well
how can we make this really worth it and
every character gets that treatment
every single one and there's a lot of
great character scenes in this movie
that this movie had such a great blend
of action sequences mixed with great
character scenes and plot provoking
scenes and twists and turns the music is
great the effects are good like the
action is mesmerizing just the first
matter you see you'll be like whoa this
is awesome and there are some unique
things they do like that we want to
touch on more the review of standout
moments in space opera the sequences
where I'm gonna remember how that went
down one thing I really enjoyed about
this movie is the way that they sort of
tempered the balance because you know
every fight sequence battle sequence is
really cool and really Star Wars II but
also you know entirely necessary yeah
you know so it does start to feel like a
war epic partly because of those action
scenes but they're also super awesome
because they're you know futuristic and
yes Star Wars they did themselves a
service by really paying attention to
the stakes and making it a build up
movie because it's not a ton of heavy
action throughout now but it does reward
you for paying attention and for you
know sticking with the characters and
yeah it gives them all you know pretty
interesting artists it's two and a half
hours as well earned and another cool
thing that I was I was saying in I think
when we did a reaction to the
behind-the-scenes featurette when they
then they talked about the Crystal Fox I
was excited for seeing are they gonna
introduce new creatures to us and they
do that like there's several new
creatures in here I will look up the
names to again the review but they all
come to mind they all have their
specific types of personalities we're
gonna be all over pours oh oh yeah but
there's even more than the pores and the
Crystal Fox there's other features as
well that you really get to a good sense
of who these creatures are yeah they had
these like cultural elements and you're
like that's another thing that I really
appreciate about a Star Wars movie is
because you get to know sort of the the
other elements of the universes and you
know
the other ventures are like and what
their habitats are and how they behave
and the force awakens you don't really
get new creatures you kind of get the
cantina 2.0 and then you get Maz and
that's about as far as it really good I
guess I know there's more river you
hardcore Star Wars fanatics I'm just
saying like for general audiences there
might be character there's creatures in
this specific movie they're like they
played a purpose and you're gonna
remember who these creatures are like I
can reference and be like oh yeah I
remember that creature there
hand-to-hand combats are great gum
battles the the ship sequences the
lightsaber sequences dude the Jedi felt
like warriors in this movie they felt
like samurai I loved it and every
lightsaber sequence again they didn't
overuse them or anything it wasn't a
gimmick it's like every time a
lightsaber turns on its a moment it's a
moment and that's something yeah yeah
and that's something that really caught
me up in the in the Star Wars miss of
the experience you know and I said then
from the trailers and I think this is
this is easily the best-looking Star
Wars film we've ever gone the way this
looks is striking its art this feels
like an artistic blockbuster to me yeah
yeah yeah well everything is really
designed you know just like a Star Wars
movie ought to be and always is you know
it's the imagination of the different
worlds you're seeing and the different
machinery and how everything works is so
detailed and so vast and yeah and they
do a great job of balancing out with
what their CG elements are and their
practical elements it feels like a real
lived-in universe and the story this is
immediate as this one is sort of you're
watching one situation kind of ripple
out and get better and worse and better
and worse until it all culminates in it
and it does so with a nice balance I
think and a good pace felt like an
appropriate middle segment of something
but also felt like you know its own
piece yeah it's it's it's the closest
comparison you can give is like Empire
or like a Lord of the Rings installment
yeah this is ours yeah this is helms
deep I really appreciated the way that
they wrote this and the way they
captured it everything is sort of in
service of the whole idea every element
is honed and the music also beyond the
classics core elements the new stuff is
great too I wouldn't even call it a
darker Star Wars movie I would call it a
heavier story yeah like I think rogue
one's a bit darker this was just heavier
than weight and the stakes of the
situation
hi and in a palpable way and the music
matched that to absolutely John Williams
man he's still dueling I still killing
it still making and there's some
excellent sound design in this film all
the technical stuff is it's the best
it's ever been if I had some complaints
about the movie it's really a couple
minor ones I like John boyega a lot and
I really like Finn I even like what they
do with him in this movie and for the
majority of it issue that I found with
the use of Finn was I felt like a lot of
it he wasn't really growing as a
character I kind of sort of feel like
they were looking for something for him
to do yeah yeah it took a while it takes
longer for his story to start paying
yeah I guess you I feel like the last
half of Finn's story is better than the
first half yeah yeah and by the end
you're like okay yeah and also the use
of Captain phasma is better than force
awakens that's for sure but it doesn't
really make up for it yeah I feel I feel
a little bummed out for it Gwendoline
Christie just cuz I'm like you could
have been anyone in there especially
when you see the trailers you're like oh
man
this is what we were waiting for by the
time you you get to her character in
this film you're like it's cooler it's a
moment but it's not a huge yeah it's not
like but why do I know when Chris he's
gonna miss done man and I was a little
bummed out by that movie sort of has
everything you want and then and then
more and it's like thought out it's it's
surprising you know it makes some bold
choices and it's a bit heavier but you
know I think it's it's all the better
for us if we were to give a consensus on
this I just realized I just want to use
their Stardust app before that so here's
our consensus on Star Wars alright
I keep this plain and simple yeah this
is probably my favorite Star Wars movie
of all time yeah well if I could give it
more than five stars I would give it
more than five stars actions great the
characters are phenomenal story is great
is such a beautiful film from beginning
and it is a epic masterpiece compelling
it subverts your expectations a bit
takes it in places you're not expecting
but that are heavily steeped in the Star
Wars these you know just it's incredible
best stars I've ever seen no idea when
this video is up on YouTube hopefully
you enjoyed our review
anyhow keep a lookout for spoiler review
or might be up already so go watch our
spoiler review who knows I'm preparing
for the future and every sentence I say
so did you see the last Jedi where would
you rank it in terms of your favorite
Star Wars movie or did you hate it if
you did put it in the comment boxes
everyone's respectful of everyone's
opinion subscribe to the real rejects
please click that notification bell if
this is up on YouTube follow us on
social media
make sure to become a patron oject today
while you're at it we post a lot of
exclusive content over at our patreon
it's become like a second YouTube
channel of ours we interact a lot over
there uncut and last but not least
download the start us app and follow us
first at the real rejects people join
the stuff just community